[Musique]
on ne le répétera jamais assez pour
éviter la propagation de la coved 19
il faut se laver les mains encore
faut-il que ce soit efficace et bien
souvent cela laisse à désirer car il
reste des zones balnéaires ouailles et
qui peuvent devenir des vecteurs de
contamination
[Musique]
se laver les mains convenablement avec
du savon est donc essentiel
parce que le virus peut vivre de 24
heures à plusieurs jours sur les
différents types de surface
redémarrez qu'il est la bonne façon de
se laver les mains bon frédéric je vous
ai observé leur disons que ce n'est pas
une technique parfaite c'était rapide
quand on se lave les mains il faut
prendre le temps de couvrir toutes les
surfaces
et si ce que je vais tenter de vous
démontrer avec la gouache et les gains à
la fin mes gains devraient bien couverts
de gouache sa demande que mon lavage de
mains soit bien fait bon frédéric je
vais vous montrer une première
expérience et comment vous vous êtes
laver les mains ce que ça donne
alors je vais prendre la gouache je vais
en mettre une petite fille dans mes
mains ça va être comme le savon et je me
procure pas se laver les mains
voyez qu'on oublie le déçu des mains on
oublie entre les doigts il ya plein de
gens les poignets qui sont pas faits
donc ça c'est quand on se lève juste les
mains comme ce rapide hausse est ce que
ça donne
non
[Musique]
maintenant quelle est la vraie bonne
façon c'est la paix ok je veux démontrer
avec la gouache qui représente notre
savant on emmène dans la paume de la
main
quand on se lève les mains on est
toujours no - avant de mettre le savon
le juste une démonstration que je fais
avec des gains de la gouache mais ça
permet d'en fait ça irait moins nombreux
quand on mouille avant de mettre le
sable première étape pour un spot la
paume des mains en sang de m
on frotte l'extérieur le bcd main et
l'antre entre une loi
bon on voit ce que ça donne il me reste
encore de 2,6 des doigts le bout des
doigts qui a presque touché du tout on
convient tourner le bout des doigts dans
la paume de mail la prochaine étape
c'est de faire un espèce de ce club
comme les chirurgies devient frotter les
worms ans en 2020 comme ceux de boeing
là encore ici j'ai pas tout à fait
réussi mais vous voyez que ce qui reste
les poussent autour des poignets et
l'extérieur des mains où souvent on va à
côté nos mains sur des surfaces qui
peuvent être contaminées selon qu'on
veut bien faire leproux
on voit que ça colombien est la dernière
étape des sera de finir avec l'extérieur
de la maille et une poignée
[Musique]
donc une fois qu'on a fait ça on est pas
mal bien on a pas mettre bien couvrir
toutes les surfaces de nomme donc
ensuite on fait un chantage et on
s'essuie les mains avec le pape mais
quand on aura un état la maison
évidemment rendre service à ceux qui
utilisent le papier on recommande des
projets au lieu de frotter sa hériteront
il ya certaines personnes qui ont des
bijoux qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on se
lave les mains ça c'est quelque chose
qui va rester contaminée
et puis on va te l'avais bien les
poignets comme on vient de le démontrer
mais là notre brasserie qui est en roue
va redescendre pour contaminer nos mains
donc les bijoux le moins possible
[Musique]